بصي انا انا الاستاذ حلمي طبعا الموسيقار
كبير ولا ولا يستطيع احد ان يقلل من
انجازه ولكن هو بيتناقض في اقواله هو نفسه
قال
والصحافه نشرت انه قال ان اصاله عايزه
تعمل ترند وان هو منعم
يقصد بالترند احمد سالم
[موسيقى]
هو بس هو ساعات يتناقد انه 180 درجه انه
وان هو لسه محتاج لتدريبات عشان يطلع
الاوبرا دلوقتي انا شايف بيتراجع قضيه و80
درجه
[موسيقى]
ساحه الجميع الحقيقه انه البروفات تمت
الاوبرا المصريه مش في بيت اصاله ولا في
ستوديو خاص هي تعمل له مش ممكن احد يعمل
بروفات في دار الاوبرا عريقه زي الاوبرا
المصريه هو من غير ما يبقى في معروف مين
ده هيعمل ايه هو بيقول لم يستكمل الاوراق
او انه ما جاءش ده ده هو منعنع زوم
الافتتاح يعني مثلا لو قلنا كان قصدي يوم
الغناء لو قلنا النهارده كانت يوم الاربع
فالخميس منى طب ده هو هيبقى اكثر واحد
حريص على انه يخلص اوراقه مش انه يتعرب من
ان هو يقدم اللي هم عايزينه هيبقى اسمه
بتاعي يعني حاجات كده
تفاصيل يعني بسيطه واللي عايز اقوله كمان
حاجه مهمه في اي حفله في الدنيا بيحصل هو
اولا مش جاي يغني منفردا لا بيحصل فقره
كده بانه مثلا حد يطلع على المسرح موجود
في الصاله وده حصل حتى بالصدفه في حفله
اصاله انه في بنت طلعت واا حضنتها ممكن
الاثنين كانوا
وبعدين قالت لها انت بتحب الغناء قالت لها
انا بحب اغني وبغني لكن انا بتغني يعني
اصل انا طلبت منها انت تغني هل اخذت اذن
الاوبرا اكيد لا البنت بس كل الحكايه همم
اتكسفت فنزلت من على المسرح بعد ما كان
ممكن هي دي فقره يعني ايه في جزء كده
بيبقى مش شرط يبقى منظم 100% هو الرغم ذلك
ال همم
الراجل حضر برباب داخل الاوبرا المصريه بس
اللي انا شايفه انه حلمي تراجع 180 درجه
وده كويس
هل انت ترى ان الاوبرا يمكن ان تكون مصرحا
للمبتدئين
[موسيقى]
اللي هم عنده بذره موهبه مؤكد من حقهم ان
يصعد مش يعمل حفله ممكن يبقى فيه فقره
يعني ممكن محمد منير يقدم حد مثلا همم
راغب علامه يقدم حد انا شايف ان ده وانا
متحمل يعني انا ك- كمطرب كبير ستار اا زي
كاظم
الاسماء الكبيره اللي موجوده في عالمنا
العربي كله يتحمل المسؤوليه الادبيه ويبقى
نوع من الدعمه بعد كده ينطلق خاصه ان
المطرب ده غنى قبل كده في همم
ففي الصاوي ودي ودي
مكان يعني محترم جدا وبيغني اغاني حزينه
واغاني يعني وحتى لما بقول بكره يا حبيبي
انا شايف وكانه بيتكلم عن نفسه يعني اول
علاقه مع الجمهور لما غنى بكره غنوه ورده
وتلحين البرتقال العظيم كمال الطويل قالها
باسلوبه وكانه يكون ايضا بكره يحلو السهر
ونحضر القمر بيقولوا لنفسه فانا رايي ان
القادم بالنسبه له افضل وانا سعيد بانه
حلمي بكر بيتراجع عن اقواله لان اقواله
مسجله ومكتوبه وكلها اتهام كلها اتهامات
الحقيقه وهو كان متحمل مسؤوليه هو انت
راجع قال الاوبرا لا هو قبل كده بيقول انا
مش ممكن وحاجات كده فانا مبسوط انه يعني
بيعود
للقراءه الصحيحه
شوفي اذا السيد حلمي همم بده يرد عليك
شكرا جزيل الشكر الناقد الفني طارق
الشناوي
هل تترغب في الرد على ما قاله طارق
الشناوي يعرف ان انا عمري
قبل منه انا سمعت فيديو واشد به ولكن نظام
الاوبرا لو عمل بورما في الاوبرا وفوقه
اداره الاوبرا بتتعمل بروفا من غير ما
يكون عندها علم واساله اداره الاوبرا
واساله لجنه التحضيريه فقالوا له ابني
احنا موافقين طب تعال قابلنا فيه في ميعاد
يوم كذا
يا استاذ طارق
شكرا جزيلا لكم